قل اخويا مبروك لنا كاملين مبروك لنا
والامه العربيه وبروك ليسنر وبروك كل يوم
وابوشه ماشي بغريبي
ماذا يعني هذا الفوز للجمهور المغربي هذا
الفوز هو فوز كبير لبس المغاربه ولا
بالنسبه للجميع العرب وادي الفوز
كايفتاخروا بالجميع العرب لانه فوز جاء من
قلب الدوحه اللي دوله عربيه اول دوله
المغرب
طبعا هذا فخر بس للمغرب بس للعرب كله هذا
فخلينا كاملين
وديما مغرب وان شاء الله نوصلوا النهائي
ونزورها للمغربيه ونفخر الفخر لكل العرب
[موسيقى]
هل عوضك فوز المغرب اليوم عن مباراه الامس
ولا للامانه يعني انا الصراحه ماني حزين
ولو على ريال قطري يندفع في هذه المباراه
ام تعونا ما في كل دقيقه حتى في كل ثانيه
صخب جماهيري روح عند اللعيبه اليوم متعه
ونتمنى لا تنقطع هذه المتعه وانا اشوف انه
المنتخب المغربي اقدر منتخب في المواصله
مواصله السير في هذه البطوله والى الامام
انطباعاتكم وشعوركم اليوم
والله شعورنا لا يوصف همم احنا اليوم
للشباب كلهم كانوا مساجين ولاعبوه واعطوا
الجهد ديالهم كامل وكنتمنى لهم الخير ان
شاء الله في المستقبل الجايه ان شاء الله
بالدور 16 وكانشكرون بزاف وديما مغربي
ديما مغرب والحمد لله همم الفوز هذا وصاحب
محمد السادس نصره الله العرب وهنا كان
نقول هنا جايين واحنا بغينا المانيا بقينا
على المانيا باش ننتقموا المنتخب
[تصفيق]
فرحانين ومبسوطين وفرحاني على التاهل
ومبروك للمنتخب المغربي ولكل الامه
العربيه وهذا اهداء لكل هم العربيه بالفوز
العربي وشكرا على قطر لاستضافتها والتنظيم
المميز اللي هو اكثر ان شاء الله
معنا ويكونوا رجال اكثر من هذا اللي
فرحونا يزيدوا فرحونا ان شاء الله ونتمنى
من عند الله
ويلعبوا بالنفس
هلال ماذا يعني هذا الفوز لجماهير العربيه
عامه كونك مشجع غير المغرب الله يبارك فيك
والله فرحه العرب كلهم يعني المنتخب
المغربي ما شاء الله تبارك الرحمن انا
اشوف افضل منتخب عربي في المونديال لعب
تكتيك ما شاء الله عليك تبارك الرحمن
والله يوفقهم ان شاء الله
ممكن نفوت الدور الثاني ان شاء الله يكون
مع المانيا واليابان
دور ثاني ان شاء الله معنا الله تعالى
والجميع العربي ان شاء الله